Welcome back. This is Unit 6 of Programming Languages.
And the story, thus far, is that we started
with a big Web page that might contain embedded JavaScript.
And we did Lexing or Lexical Analysis
to break it up into a list of tokens.
And once we had that list of tokens, we did Parsing
to check those tokens against a formal grammar
and produce a Parse Tree.
More recently, we've learned how to do
Interpreting to walk up and down a parse tree--
with an environment--and figure out what the final result is supposed to be.
We often call that Meaning or Semantics.
In this Unit, we're going to put that all together
to build a unified Web browser,
and it's going to require all the tricks that we've learned,
up to this point--including things like
how to debug or what can go wrong
if you interpret a program with an infinite loop.
Let's talk about the Architecture for our Web browser.
Just as engineers or architects that build buildings in the Real World
like to have blueprints or plans--or some
notion of how that design is going to come together--
we try to do the same thing in software engineering.
We want to have a software architecture,
a list of major components, and a design that incorporates all of them.
Our first step is to find our Web page
and lex it and parse it until we have an Abstract Syntax Tree.
Most commonly, our HTML interpreter
will walk over the Abstract Syntax Tree that we got from the parsing,
and it may find elements in there that are embedded JavaScript.
So then we'll have to call the JavaScript interpreter on them.
In most cases, at some point the JavaScript code from the user
will call "write" or "document_write",
and that's that function that says:
If I'm in JavaScript, display this on the resulting Web page.
Because the meaning of a JavaScript program that calls "write"
is that that text should be displayed,
we'll definitely want to store all of the text from "write"
so that we remember to include it in the Web page later.
Eventually, the JavaScript fragments will be done executing
and will be back to the HTML interpreter,
which will have received all of those
strings from "write", and it will take them--
plus all of the normal HTML elements--
and call the graphics library to make a pretty picture of them.
Eventually, at the end of the day--
we end up with an image of the Web page,
and that's what we wanted from our simple Web browser.